hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a drama and science fiction
movie called lx 2048.
in the future humans have adapted to be
nocturnal due to not being able to go
out unprotected in the sun ai and vr
have taken over most aspects of life
this event leads to mental health
problems as everyone is taking a
substance called lithium x to numb their
depression
there are also clones the only ones that
can go out during time
a man named adam bird is on a day
meeting with a doctor named dr reese who
is giving a checkup on adam's body adam
has been skipping his medication for a
long time
later she tells adam the results that
his heart is in failing condition
knowing this the doctor brings up the
program that he's in called premium
three
she also tells adam about how the
program will help his wife and their
three kids after he's gone
hearing this makes adam shocked and
depressed she then tells adam if he's
reluctant he can ask for his wife to put
up the requests
he then refuses
turns out he and his wife are currently
separated before leaving he asks dr
reese if she's a clone it is revealed
that dr reese is a clone later adam
calls his wife and tells her that he's
dying from heart failure but his wife
doesn't really care about his condition
than she hangs up
after that he goes to work in a safety
suit to block the sun
there he's alone meeting with his
coworker inside vr called realm
he says that their company almost goes
under and they need to stop investing in
vr tech because there's a new technology
called chip
in the end his advice got ignored by his
coworker
at night he visits his wife named rina
to tell his condition in person he tells
about his heart condition and his plan
before he dies to support his family
reina then says that he needs to figure
it out himself before he dies so he
won't be dying like such a loser
then he goes home feeling sad
at home adam immediately looks for
information on someone named donald
stein who is the engineer of premium 3
and chip
after that he goes to the realm and
meets with his virtual girlfriend named
maria
not long after donald suddenly points a
gun at him in his awkward sleeping
position
donald asks him how adam knows about him
and his connection with premium 3 and
chip adam then tells him that he knows
him from when he first signed up for
premium 3. it is revealed that premium 3
is an insurance company that will make a
clone version for people that join the
program
donald then starts to open up and
reveals that he first invented premium 3
and chip to construct his virtual lover
then adam also reveals about his
condition with rena at first because
each one of his family is busy connected
to the realm every day he feels empty
because of this he starts to have
intercourse using a doll with his
virtual lover maria this action of adam
is seen by rena and then she files a
restraining order against him supported
by his action and how he skips his
medication then donald tells him to
forget about rena and offers him a clone
of maria hearing this adam looks
enlightened and forgot about his company
the next night rina comes to his house
she convinces him to replace himself
with a clone and asks him to enjoy his
days before he dies
at first adam is very angry about this
but in the end he calms down and accepts
what rina wants him to do
because adam already agrees to what rena
wants rina changes adam's name to
richard burbidge and his clone is
already in the making process
when rina goes out to her car suddenly
she gets hit by a car and dies
later police come to ask him about how
he wants to clone rena he then
immediately orders a clone of rein into
his house
the next night a clone of maria suddenly
comes to his house
this makes adam feel very happy and very
shocked at the same time while maria
goes to take a bath adam checks her bag
and finds a tiny chip it is revealed
that this tiny chip contains everything
a person is
moments later maria says that she likes
adam but she doesn't love him so she
wants to leave to feel real love
this leaves adam in a state of panic and
depressed the next night there's someone
banging hard on the front door of his
house
this makes adam panicking scared but he
goes to check the door anyway
turns out this someone is adam's clone
that has been ordered by rena before
adam's clone is better at everything
starting from how he plays guitar and
his body is also better than the
original adam
adam then feels so scared and confused
about how can someone construct an
upgraded life with the exact same memory
he also says that both of them only need
one atom so he takes his gun and points
it to the clone because the clone is
designed with a self-defense system the
clone fights back at adam
eventually they dropped the gun and it
accidentally shot right between the eyes
of one of the atom and it caused him to
die in place after that adam buries the
other atom the surviving atom then goes
back to his home and not long after that
rina's clone arrives at his house it is
revealed that the surviving atom is
adam's clone at the end of the film the
two clones plan on cloning their three
kids to make a family full of clones
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching